Welcome, so this week we have a grid set up.
So pause the video and write down these diagrams if you need them for different ways to come
into a grid.
There's the simplest to a more advanced version, whatever your level.
So we've already gone through the basics of getting to an obstacle or fence.
It needs to be perpendicular and the horse needs to be traveling over the center of the
obstacle.
If your horse still has trouble with this, use only cross rails or start with the exercise
at the poles on the ground.
So first order of business is balance.
You want your balance to be right over your toes and your feet, legs traveling up over
your knees, through your hips and out over the top of your head.
At every point through the grid, you want that balance to remain the same in your body.
In order to do that, we need to bend our joints accordingly through the exercise and through
the movement of the horse to absorb.
Secondly, to keep our balance, the first thing we want to practice is grabbing main.
The grid is a great place to learn to grab the main because the horse is only traveling
in a straight line.
There's no turns.
So grab the main as you approach and keep a hold of it the whole time to keep your balance
right over the center of gravity, which should be underneath your stirrup.
The goal of today is to get your balance and be able to maintain it.
First grabbing main and then being able to let go and not have to use your reins to use
the main for balance using your core strength only.
Trust your animal, trust the balance that you have and eventually you'll be able to
let go.